hallo und herzlich willkommen zur heute
schon ich habe direkt mal eine richtig
tolle nachricht diese folge der heute
show wird komplett praxis freie heute
show ja zum ersten mal seit wochen
angeblich war zu heute wieder irgendwas
in london aber ganz ehrlich wen juckts
die engländer sollen sich einfach melden
wenn sie ihre insel fertig versenkt
haben und wir erwachsenen reden solange
über wichtige themen mein vorschlag die
chinesen kaufen gerade ganz europa
wussten sie das ja es fakt italien haben
sie schon im sack italien haben sie im
sack offiziell teil der neuen
seidenstraße und jetzt sind wir dran
deutschland der chinesische konzern
huawei soll wohl mithelfen beim ausbau
unseres 95 g handynetzes wissen sie da
wobei weil ich 5g brauchen wir das
überhaupt meine so schlecht sieht es in
deutschland noch gar nicht aus mit dem
empfang du das macht was aus hätte gar
nicht gedacht
oben auf dem dach da hat kein guter
anfang
mach was aus dir wir brauchen kein
schnelleres netz wir brauchen höhere
trecker das ist alles
so problem wenn huawei unser neues 5g
netz baut dann gibt das den chinesen
eventuell ganz neue abhör möglichkeiten
das ist fakt leider und in china sind
firmen tatsächlich gesetzlich
verpflichtet der staatsführung relevante
daten weiterzuleiten
das müssen die holen wir uns da also mit
huawei quasi ja so eine art trojanische
frühlingsrolle ins haus
der havarist smartphones chef meint nein
das ist ein gerücht und stimmt einfach
nicht tatsache ist wir sind nicht nur
bei der qualität die besten sondern auch
bei der sicherheit und beim schutz
privater daten verbraucher und
netzanbieter können uns vertrauen da
muss auch selber lachen haben das
gemerkt
übrigens gibt es bislang natürlich keine
beweise dass huawei in deutschland
spioniert sie haben auch schon am 3g und
4g netz mitgebaut und china ist
natürlich unser wichtigster
handelspartner das ist dann immer eine
abwägung geschichte da muss man sehr
sehr weise sein so weise die sie hier
zum beispiel ja konfuzius sagt huawei
kann man das nehmen oder nicht nehmen da
muss man eben mit china darüber sprechen
dass eben nicht die firma einfach die
daten an den start up gibt ja einfach
mit ihnen reden war leute aber nicht
weitergeben die dort new york ja das
heißt übersetzt natürlich sind das keine
traumpartner die chinesen aber sie
kaufen hält unsere autos und zwar viele
und so wird aus kohls mädchen ruckzuck
in china kohls mädchen ja das nennt man
realpolitik du kommst an den chinesen
nicht vorbei
dieser gigantische mag diese massen von
kunden hier ein spaßbad in peking
an dem ganz normalen dienstagvormittag
wobei richtig voll wird es natürlich
erst am wochenende das ist klar
wieso eine lavalampe wende zulage
hinguckt was sie da gesehen haben das
sind alles kunden von uns alles kunden
andererseits sind manche deutsche
experten besorgt denn 5g ermöglicht ja
nicht nur höher aufgelöste katzen videos
sondern auch zukunftstechnologien in die
sich die chinesen dann vielleicht ein
haken könnten rein hecken medizintechnik
oder selbstfahrender autos im prinzip
kann der chinesische präsident sie dann
abends mit seinem huawei tablet
praktisch ganz deutschland versteuern
ja wenn er will knipste bei ihm zu hause
mit nenner nacht über alexa das licht an
und spielt volle lotte chinesische musik
[Musik]
ja oder er könnte jeden morgen bei uns
die komplette deutsche bahn legen aber
das muss er ja gar nicht
ja da fragt man sich wirklich ist die
heute show vor weihnachten meine damen
und herren wir müssen uns klar machen
dieses china braucht da jemand hilfe
vielleicht
dieses china ist halt schon eine sehr
spezielle diktatur mit einem
überwachungssystem
da würde sogar george orwell sagen holy
[ __ ] das habe ich nicht kommen sehen
jeder chinese jeder chinese wird bald
nach einem ausgeklügelten punktesystem
rund um die uhr sozial bewertet für den
eltern hilft kommunistische lieder singt
krieg punkte wird zu viel video spielt
verliert sie bürger werden ausgestellt
bekommen leichter kredit und einen job
die bürger dagegen dürfen nicht mehr mit
bahn und flieger reisen kam ja gerade
als meldung mehr als 20 millionen
chinesische bürger hatten im letzten
jahr schon reiseverbot wegen punktestand
jetzt wo die endgültig eine weltmacht
sind darf man china wahrscheinlich gar
nicht mehr auf menschenrechte ansprechen
eine überbetonung eine zu viel
betonung von menschen richte ist auch
nicht gesund
iss dich gesund ist nicht gesund also in
china menschenrechte ansprechen ist
wirklich nicht gesund und sie arbeiten
wir sprachen schon drüber fieberhaft an
ihrer neuen seidenstraße eine billion
unfassbare summe eine billion investiert
die volksrepublik gerade in globale
infrastruktur beziehungsweise in ihre
weltherrschaft neuerdings auch in
italien
sie haben ganz richtig gehört italien
wird chinesisch ja sie haben es so
gewollt denn die die häfen von genua und
triest werden von china gepimpt getunt
was deutschlands schönsten außenminister
aber zu einer ermahnung veranlasst
sollten einige länder glauben man kann
mit den chinesen clevere geschäfte
machen werden sie sich wundern und
irgendwann in abhängigkeiten aufwachen
und man kann so viel lernen von styling
minister heiko maas meine damen und
herren
dabei ist deutschland doch selber eine
art supermarkt für chinesen wie viele
deutsche marken die schon gekauft haben
wir sind inzwischen so was wie das wie
des kaisers von china im grunde ja da
kommt einiges zusammen
der roboterhersteller kuka osram der
smart wird bald in china gebaut und sie
übernehmen das ist ausdrücklich kein
witz sogar bald unser coolste modelabel
c&a dann ist es soweit dann kriegen die
chinesen den begehrten bauplan für den c
& a anorak meine damen und herren
wie ich
der mars ist nicht in der position
andere zu belehren am dienstag war der
chinesische staatspräsident in paris
merkel war auch dabei und da gab es aber
vor allem mahnende worte von emanuel
makro allerdings hier von phoenix
irgendwie hören sie meinen seltsam
übersetzt
wir brauchen nützliche freunde
rechtschaffene freunde kultivierte
freunde getreue freunde verhängnisvoll
sind falsche freunde schlafe freunde ja
ok feste freunde sind immer besser als
schlafe dann sind wir uns einig ich sage
nur hoffentlich geraten wir wägen huawei
nicht noch zwischen die fronten im
handelskrieg usa china hier trans
botschafter in berlin
rich green erkennen sie hat der groko in
einem brief offen gedroht wenn wir
deutschen huawei am netzausbau
beteiligen werden die usa die
geheimdienst zusammenarbeit mit uns
einschränken
unglaublicher tonfall wenn man bedenkt
was sich dieser diplomatie schon alles
geleistet hat warum schmeißen wir den
nicht raus für mich eines der großen
ungelösten rätsel
herzlich willkommen zu heute schon
mystery mit birte schneider
hallo wer ist richard gruner
warum redet er mit uns als hätten wir
zwei weltkriege verloren und sind eher
und melania trump vielleicht ein und
dieselbe person
denken sie da mal drüber nach viele
glauben brunel wohnt in berlin
dabei lebt er in wirklichkeit an einem
ort namens instagram und jetzt wird's
unheimlich immer exakt dasselbe grinsen
ein lächeln von dem rohr clowns
albträume kriegen
und davon kostet er tausende niemand
kann immer gleich gucken
niemand hat derartig weiße zähne
es sei denn erst gar nicht von der erde
sondern vom planeten botox
[Musik]
verstehe ich nicht ich bin in einer sehr
großen sache auf der spur
tatsächlich findet man auf der seite nur
ein bild das aus der reihe fällt hier
seine und lola takt auf den rücksitz
eines autos ist übrigens die
dienstlimousine von angela merkel und
das fast das deutsch amerikanische
verhältnis eigentlich ganz gut zusammen
natürlich sind die chinesen alles andere
als die guten aber die letzten die uns
über cyber sicherheit belehren dürfen
sind die amis denken wie wir haben den
nsa skandal schon vergessen was war noch
mal der nsa skandal
mein gott die nsa sammelt weiter unsere
daten jeder der nur eine sekunde im
internet war hartner eigene akte bei
denen die lesen e mails oder in ihrem
fall postkarten die haben hier handys
abgehört ja handys doch nur von
islamistischen gefährder ganz genau
islamistische gefährder wie sie hier
weißt gar nicht weiß gar nicht ob man
die inzwischen erwischt hat
brandgefährlich angst vor huawei nie
verkehrt aber was ist denn mit dem
us-konzern cisco über deren netz die
eu-kommission ausspioniert wurde google
facebook und youtube geben unsere daten
seit jahren direkt an die nsa weiter und
nur zur erinnerung die oberste etage der
us-botschaft in berlin hat keine fenster
aber infrarotbilder zeigen der
energiebedarf ist enorm sein was so viel
wärme abstrahlt das ist bestimmt die
private sauna landschaft von donald
trump oder nein da läuft den ganzen tag
ein sehr großer thermomix
das ist alles traurig wird ist alles
traurig amis chinesen was ich immer sage
wir deutschen sind wirklich die letzten
guten auf der welt ganz genau vor allem
horst seehofer wenn es nach wendts
nachdem geht soll der verfassungsschutz
künftig nicht mehr nur daten von
personen ab 14 jahren speichern können
die altersgrenze soll stattdessen
ersatzlos wegfallen
wer alle drei stunden laut schreibe es
entweder baby oder muss ihn keiner es zu
jung horst seehofer will wissen wo sich
jeder einzelne sperma aufhält und was
sie verdammt noch mal vor hat ja gott
sei dank wird gott sei dank aber sagt
sie wenn die amis unseren deutschen
geheimdiensten bald wirklich nicht mehr
helfen nach
die brauchen wir doch gar nichts der bnd
hat eigene high tech überwachungsmethode
so hier gerade im bnd labor entwickelt
es sieht aus wie eine zeitung aber
anja daeschler michael beschreibt auf
facebook wilke du bist der letzte arsch
nur große fresse ich möchte ich mal
sehen wenn es hart auf hart kommt dann
schaust du dir in die hose warte ab ein
sprichwort sagt man trifft sich immer
zweimal im leben mach weiter so mit
einer großen fresse wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 im zweiten oder hier
auf youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren